nos piden en el problema 9 hacer esa
división de polinomios como cualquier
división larga debemos encontrar el
lugar con el grado más alto en este caso
es el 2x cuantas veces cabe 2x en 2x a
la cuarta cuando el 12 entra una vez en
2 y el x entra x a las tres veces en x
4a vamos a hacer un poquito más de
espacio para poder hacer la operación
directamente aquí no tener que volver a
reescribir lo voy a hacerlo en otro
color entonces aquí es x al cubo x al
cubo multiplicamos x al cubo por 7 pues
va a ser 7 x al cubo 7 x al cubo
positivo x al cubo por 2 x va a ser 2 x
a la cuarta
esto lo restamos
como cualquier otra división esto se va
21 x cúbica menos 7 x cúbica va a ser
igual a 14 x cúbica y bueno vamos a
bajar este término que es más 35 x
cuadrado
cuántas veces cabe 2x en 14 x cúbica el
2 va a caber siete veces más 7 y x cabe
x al cuadrado veces en x cúbica 7 x
cuadrado 7x cuadrada por 7 7 por 7 49 49
dispositivo x cuadrado x cuadrada y 7 x
cuadrada x 2 x va a ser igual a 14 x
cúbica restamos
14 x cúbica menos 14 x cúbica va a ser 0
35 x cuadrado menos 49 x cuadrada va a
ser igual a menos 14 x cuadrado
bajamos el siguiente término que es
menos 37 x menos 37 equis y vemos
cuántas veces cabe el 2x en el menos 14
x cuadrada el 2 cabe 7 veces menos 7
veces x cabe una vez más en x cuadrada
va a ser menos 7 x menos 7 x por 7 7 por
7 49 pero como es menos menos 49
- 7 x x 2x bashir igual a menos 14 x
cuadrado y esto lo restamos pero si
restamos es como si estuviéramos aquí
cambiando los signos de estos elementos
de acá menos menos va a ser más menos
por menos va a ser más entonces podemos
decir que es menos 37 49 x va a ser
igual a 12 x 12 x positivo porque este
que es el más grande tiene el signo
positivo menos 14 x cuadrada más 14 x
cuadradas se van va a ser cero bajamos
el siguiente término que es 46 más 46 y
que número de veces cabe 2x en 2x pues
va a caber
seis veces 6 por 7 42 42 positivo 6 por
2 12 x 12 x y esto lo resto
46 42 va a ser igual a 4 12 x 12 x va a
ser igual a 0 así que nuestra respuesta
es voy a escribirlo acá abajo el
resultado de la adición x cúbica más 7 x
al cuadrado
- 7 x + 6 y para representar este
residuo lo escribimos + 4 entre 2 x 7
lo que lo dividimos nos x 7 y este es
nuestro resultado que es la opción de
veamos el siguiente problema el problema
número 10
nos piden realizar esta multiplicación
de polinomios vamos a escribirlo de otra
manera que a mí me parece un poco más
clara para hacer la operación puede
escribir 3x cuadrada
cuadrada más x
-4 y aquí abajo escribo esto cuidando de
que correspondan los lugares con los
mismos tipos de términos en la misma
posición entonces aquí es 2 x 2 x menos
muy bien y esto va a ser una
multiplicación
ok menos 5 x menos 4 menos por menos es
más 5 por 4 es 20 menos 5 por x menos 5
x noten que los términos con x van
quedando aquí en la misma columna los
términos constantes aquí y los que
tienen x cuadrada van a estar en la
misma columna el orden siempre es
importante no se les olvide menos 5 x 3
x al cuadrado va a ser igual a menos 3 x
5 15 x cuadrado
y ahora voy a explicar esto por todo lo
de arriba 2x por 4 va a ser igual a como
este es con x lo tengo que escribir aquí
4 por 2 8 menos 8 x 2x por equis va a
ser igual a más 2 x cuadradas
y 2 x x 3 x cuadrada va a ser igual
2 x 36 x al cubo ok
hacemos esta suma como en cualquier
multiplicación vamos a sumar estos 2
aquí me queda 20
20 - 5 x menos 8 x es igual a menos 13 x
- 15 x 42 x cuadrada es igual a menos 13
x cuadrada
y aquí el único término con x al cubo se
queda acá se dice quizá al cubo y este
es mi resultado que corresponde con la
opción b ahora pasemos al siguiente
problema
nos piden hacer esta operación suma de
polinomios pero aquí tengo una
multiplicación que afecta a todo esto
que está entre paréntesis así que voy a
describir todo esto pero ahora voy a
distribuir este menos 2 en estos
elementos entonces me queda menos 2 x
cuadrada más 6 x más 1 - 2 x 4 x al
cuadrado es menos 8 x al cuadrado menos
2 x menos 3 x menos por menos es más 2 x
36 x menos 2 x 1 es menos 2 esto aquí es
igual vamos a reparar los términos
similares
aquí tenemos 1 con x cuadrada aunque
otro con x cuadrada menos 8 x cuadrada
menos 2 x cuadrada es igual a menos 10 x
cuadrado
6x aquí aquí tenemos otro término con x
6 x 6 x 12 x
1 - 2 es igual a menos 1
y este es mi resultado que corresponde
con la opción de finalmente pasemos al
último problema de este vídeo que es el
problema número 12 hacer esta
multiplicación que realmente creo que
ustedes la podrían resolver hasta
mentalmente pero vamos a resolverlo paso
a paso para que sigamos practicando
entonces es 6 y al cuadrado menos 2
por 6 haber aquí es importante el orden
en este primero
tengo el 6 al cuadrado no tengo ningún
término en dejó un espacio aquí y el
término constante menos 2 y díaz por acá
y el término por el que lo voy a
multiplicar lo escribo acá esto tiene
terminó en y entonces va en esta columna
62 y ahora puedo hacer esta
multiplicación
2 x menos 24 no hay terminan de aquí
entonces esto se queda vacío 2 por 6
llamada 12 y al cuadrado y ahora
multiplico 67 por menos 2 va a ser igual
a menos 12 y 6 10 por 6 ya cuadrada va a
ser igual a 6 por 6 36 36 y kubica no
tengo que estoy dejando vacío los
espacios donde no hay términos al
cuadrado o constantes ahora hago la suma
de estos me queda menos 4 menos 12 y más
12 y cuadrada
36 de kubica
y este es mi el resultado que es la
opción de nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo